-Welcome back, everybody.
Questlove and I are about
to play a frightening new game.
Do you know what the game is?
-We are?
I have no clue...
-It's a frightening new game.
This is called
the "Jump Scare Challenge."
Here we go.
-♪ Jump Scare Challenge ♪
♪ Jump Scare Challenge ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-You didn't even know you were
playing this until just now.
-Oh, man.
-I'm so excited.
But we're going to need
another player, everyone.
You can see him
in the scary new movie "Nope,"
which is out this Friday
in theaters and IMAX.
Give it up for Daniel Kaluuya!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah. Yeah. He's feeling it.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
You know what I'm saying.
Come on. Good to see you.
Good to see you, buddy.
Alright.
Daniel, you can have a seat
right here, bud.
Take that.
Have a seat right there.
Now, here's how
this is going to work.
We're all going to watch
a jump-scare video
together at the same time.
-Yeah.
-Whoever can keep
their composure the most
and react the least
when the jump scare happens
wins that round.
-Alright. Cool.
Alright. Cool. I got ya.
-I feel like you're
going to be good at this.
-I'm going to be good.
-Alright, alright.
Everyone put on a --
We have monitors here.
Alright. Everyone
put on their headphones.
There's a left and right side.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I got you.
Alright, here we go.
Alright. Alright.
I can't hear anything.
Alright.
Let's play the first video.
[ Sweet flute music plays ]
[ Audience laughter ]
-I'm scared already.
-Wait. Why is the audience
reacting like that?
-Pay attention.
-Are they watching?
They're watching it.
Are you guys watching it?
-Audience: Yeah.
-I know something's
going to happen.
-[ Creature screams ]
-Aah!
[ Laughter ]
[Bleep]
Oh, wait. I'm sorry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Never --
I've never heard you curse.
-You think he's scared?
-Dude, that was real.
-You said some crazy curse
in that one. I go...
-I think I said
three curse words.
-Yeah, you said
You made up a new one.
Oh, can we see --
-No!
-We're going to show
the slow-motion replay
and see who reacted.
[ Laughter ]
-Bow, bow.
-You were fantastic.
-But I looked cool, though.
-That's what he is. Cool, man.
Alright. Alright.
So, the winner --
The winner is
Daniel there, yeah.
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's go again.
Let's go again.
-Alright, man.
Here we go. Ready?
Play the second video.
Here we go.
[ Ominous music plays ]
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-"Stare at the spiral."
-Isn't there something
weird happening?
-Yeah, there's something weird.
It's already hypnotizing you.
"Please watch
'The Tonight Show.'"
[ Laughter ]
-"Don't watch the other shows."
-It's a long one, huh?
-I'm not scared, man.
-I'm just dizzy.
-[ Screaming ]
-Aah!
[Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
-Did you...?
-No.
-That was creepy,
that little dude.
That little dude was creepy.
I think -- I think you might
have lost that one again,
but let's see the replay.
[ Laughter ]
-You look like you got shot
with a pellet gun.
-You're cold as ice, man.
Alright.
I think you're going to
win this one, man.
2 points here. Alright.
Ready for another one?
-I'm-a win this.
-Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
-Alright.
-Good luck.
-Let's play the video.
Audience member: Oh, no.
-Wait. How do they know
what this is?
-People know what this is?
-What is this? What is this?
-The audience knows
what this is?
-This is a famous one?
Hm.
Hm. Hm. Ehh!
Don't hit the wall!
Don't hit the wall.
Ahh!
-What happens
when you hit the wall?
-I don't know, man. That's where
this jump scare comes out.
-Oh, okay.
[ Creature screams ]
-Aah!
-That got me. That got me...
-That one got you?
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-That one got you, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
Can we see that one?
Can we see the replay
on that one?
[ Laughter ]
-That was you.
-That's you scared?
-That's me scared.
-That was me scared, yeah.
-You scared --
You scared is this.
[ Laughter ]
-It gets like that.
-It gets like that. Alright.
[ Wolf howls ]
Guys, you know
what that sound means?
It's time for the final round.
Whoever wins this
wins the whole thing.
Ready for this?
-Yeah.
-Alright.
Let's play the last video.
Here we go.
Oh, no.
-This is mad.
-I know.
It's already like night vision.
[ Audience groans ]
-What do you see?
-It's already night vision.
-Why'd the audience say that?
-No, 'cause it's moving.
-Oh.
-[ Woman screams ]
-That's [bleep] up.
[ All growling ]
[ All screaming ]
[Bleep, bleep]
[ Laughter ]
I was like, hey, this is --
[Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Hey!
[Bleep]
Hey! Hey! Hey.
[ Laughter ]
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
Hey. No. Hey.
-I'm sorry.
Can we see that in slow motion?
-I can't talk to anyone.
-You lost! Daniel lost!
Of all the people,
Daniel Kaluuya
is the loser tonight!
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks to Questlove,
Daniel Kaluuya.
"Nope" is in theaters
and IMAX this Friday.
Stick around. We're talking
to Daniel after the break.
Come on back.